hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over one of the most popular
variations in the Sicilian defense and
that is this fashion akan variation if
you're not familiar starts out pon e4
pawn c5 this is the Sicilian offense
Knight f3 knight c6 pawn d4 common line
after the pawn takes Knight to d4 Knight
f6 and then after Knight c3 pawn e5
attacking this nights here on d4 so many
variations where the pawn is either on
e6 or d6 but this one comes straight out
the gate pawn to e5 attacking the
Knights now the most common move we're
gonna go over a laughs you variations is
going to be Knight to b5 there's a few
others I will cover today cuz just
showing one variation in this it's not
the most exciting you may also see
Knight takes on c6 or you could see
Knight to f5 if I have played against
this before so those are the three
variations then I'm gonna be going over
in at this particular video the first
line is the Knights coming here to b5
and the main threat is Knight to d6
putting black in check here black were
to play pawn h6 then you can really see
this play out Knight to d6 check really
forced to capture here the Queen comes
down captures White has an open board
stay with the bishop hair putting a lot
of pressure on black side the board with
the Queen that's very hard to remove
here
not exactly what black wants to do so to
stop this black is gonna be playing pawn
to d6 always can't take it now cuz after
the bishop takes the Queen is now
protecting the bishop here on d6 so
after the pond comes to d6 a lot of
variations that white can go down one of
those is Knight to d5
this is threatening Knight coming to c7
check and forking the rook here on a8 to
stop that black has to take with his
night here on d5 after he takes pawn
captures here on d5 and the Knights
going to come back
to seven with the threat now of Queen to
a5 check and taking either the night
here on b5 or depending on whites
position could always take this pawn
here since the Queen and the Knights
would both be attacking this pond so
you'll see lots of variations from white
here one of those would be pawn to a4
holding down the fort has a nice little
outpost for this nights here on b5 black
needs to continue with pawn to a6 just
taking away these incremental squares
that white wants to be at enforcing the
knight to move back now really needs to
be coming back here to c3 this is the
best square be on the lookout if he
makes a mistake in plays Knight to c3
why because now Queen to a5 this is
putting their opponent into check if we
see Bishop to d2 then the Queen comes
snags this pawn here on a d5 if instead
maybe Queen to d2 that's completely fine
you can just go ahead and take that
material after the bishop takes now the
knight takes on d5 and black is now up
material the next line after pawn to d6
would be wipe down here to g5 pinning
down the knight to the Queen from here
play pawn to a6 forcing the Knights back
here a couple options that white has one
would be to bring the knight back to a3
and the other would be to take with the
bishop right here so let's go ahead and
take a look at the first one night to a3
there's really two options that black
has he has the safer one which is Bishop
to e7 stops Bishop coming here and
having to take with the pawn if you want
to be pretty aggressive you have the
line of pawn to b5 and this says that if
the bishop takes here on f6 then you
have two options you can either take
with your pawn or you can take with your
queen now if you take with your Queen
because you don't want to have double
pawns here on that file just know that
things are going to
it pretty crazy because first you're
gonna see Knight to d5 attacking the
Queen and this is also threatening what
we talked about the knight coming down
here to a c7 so the Queen comes back to
d8 now Bishop to b5 this is pinning down
the Knights pawn to b5 capture the
knight takes here on b5 this is now
setting up for the Knights coming down
to c7 as we've seen before
rook here to a7 stopping that but it's
just going to fall Queen up here to a5
to get that material back so this is the
board state that it will look like if
you're okay with that you absolutely can
go down this path now I think it's
easier to play if you just take with
your pawn but you have to be comfortable
having double pawns here so after the
pawn takes here on f6 then the Knights
gonna come down attack that pawn punt up
here to f5 double pawns go ahead and
attack the center of the board here and
then see what your opponent is going to
do but you are defending it with your
Bishop here on a c8 now white could
decide to not take this night here on f6
instead play Knight to d5 attacking this
nights here on f6 just continue with
Bishop to e7 now you do not want to have
the double pawn here on the F file if
you don't need to if they want to
capture that's fine just recapture
you're putting a lot of pressure on this
Knight can't move anywhere so in theory
you have more pieces involved into the
action so if they try something like
pawn to c4 trying to blow up this be 5
square now you can play Knight to d4
this is a really great outpost no more
pawns on the E or the C file can really
attack this Knight right here put a lot
of pressure on your opponent
the next line we'll look at is the
bishop coming to e3 and this is a tricky
one from white so I want to make sure
everyone knows how to attack it from
black standpoint you're usually gonna be
playing pawn a6 you need to force the
knight back after Knight comes to a3
then
on b5 getting ready to fork the nights
here on before but if you do this beware
of Knight to d5 if you see this the move
needs to be looked to be 8 because if
you try something else and I'll use the
extreme example with nothing going on
pawn to h6 which you're not going to be
playing is Bishop to b6 is just huge for
whites here only safe square for the
Queen is to come down here to d7
but then that allows for the night to
come c7 this is check and forking the
rook here on a7 with no real
compensation so this is not what you
want to be doing so instead to stop that
you can now play rook to b8
so both the Queen and of the rook are
both attacking at that square right
there if they want to give up their
bishop and their knights for the rook
hey that's gonna be a win in my book so
that's what they what happens if you see
b2 III at the beginning another move
that they could play instead of Bishop
to e3 is pawn to a4 I'm just saying I
want to support my night here on b5 it's
a very aggressive square same thing as
before pawn to a6 Knights gonna come
back to a3 and then from here I
recommend Bishop to g4 and there's a few
options of how they could continue if
they want to play pawn to f3 that's fine
go ahead and play Bishop to e6 this is a
development move from black giving the
bishop in the center of the board and
it's not as great of a pawn structure
for white so I feel like that is a win
if they try something else maybe Queen
to d3 then go ahead and just centralize
your rook right here this is a semi-open
file for the rook to attack if they want
to play Bishop to e2 just defending
getting ready to castle on the King side
then in this case I would go ahead and
take after the Queen takes then I think
just play pawn to d5 controlling the
center of the board so that's obviously
the most common with the knight coming
to b5 but they won't
do that one move they will see is the
night taking here on c6 they just don't
know what to do and they just decide to
take material off the board now you have
two options is black one that I don't
like a lot but some people prefer going
down this path is pawn takes here on c6
because this just opens up the door for
the Queen to take and then the King
recapture to me this is just not as fun
so if you are going to take I recommend
taking with the pawn this also allows
black to have more central pawns
controlling the center is always a win
here and then if they want to play
Bishop to c4 you can play your Bishop to
b4 getting ready to castle on the King
side this is gonna be completely fine
from black standpoint now if they don't
take here another option could be Knight
to f5 not the strongest move but it's a
outpost so you could just see this on
board if it does happen I would
recommend playing pawn to d5
aggressively attacking the center of the
board they have a couple options if they
want to take with their pawn right here
you could take with your Bishop taking
that night they could take the knight
right here and then go ahead and take
your Queen down here because more than
likely players don't like to bring their
knight back here but they should if they
play their King here then you can castle
on the Queen side attack with your rook
here and then you can take this pawn
this is gonna be a very strong move from
black here but if they do take with
their Knights then all of a sudden one
you're gonna take with your pawn but
then they have just another move that
they have to move with their Knights
just losing some tempo in the game so
both of those are gonna be good for
black now if we come back if they don't
take with their pawn maybe they take
with their knight here and think oh this
is a great outpost in this case go ahead
and take the pawn here on e4 and Black's
gonna have a very good game from here so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
thanks for watching and I will see you
guys in the next video